the Jo Rogan Experience when when dad
started talking about writing a book we
were like H there's no way you know his
his brain is is truly cyclical just like
the farm there's you know birth growth
death Decay birth growth death Decay
where do he start the chicken or the egg
who came first and for him uh you know
we had talked about him writing a book
for a very long time and honestly nobody
knew where to start um and so he was
approached by um you know some folks who
said hey we think you know you'd be a
great book writer um and Dad quickly
told them there's no way I can write a
book no way in hell I don't know where
to start and where to end they said well
let us help you so they found a ghost
writer named Emily grievin who is great
and she and dad had phone dates every
Friday for probably a year that lasted
anywhere from 2 to four hours and in
listening to the book Dad D dad narrated
it and it is like a glimpse inside of
his brain it is such a uh all of his
thoughts are there and you know I think
it's so important because you know dad
started a a business and a mission that
is going to last a lot longer than him
you know he's 69 this year and you know
the food system is not going to be fixed
uh you know by the time he is gone and
so to be part of that and to be part of
a business that's you know bigger than
one person bigger than one person's life
that last you know last so much longer I
think is so important and and people
like him have got to focus on that you
know he can't fix the food system he has
to set the groundwork for people like
you and I to fix the food system and
then to instill it in our children to
fix the food system what was the
motivation to write
this you know I felt like people needed
to know what I spent the last 25 years
learning
learning I'm not the only one that knows
it but I'm the only one that has this
particular slant on it I knew I couldn't
write a book you know I I went to the
University of Georgia and majored in
agriculture we didn't read many books we
certainly didn't write a
book when they approached us about about
writing it uh it it just seemed like the
thing to do and I give so much credit to
this am Graven the JY reference who
wrote it who
actually wrote my thoughts down on the
paper
and do you think this is a one time deal
or you going to write books I I know
damn well it
is it took me 69 years to come up with
another to put in that book I'm not
going to have
time it seems like another book though
someone should write is uh how this can
be
fixed and uh what steps need to be taken
and I think it it needs to be taken in
for sure it needs to be taken at a
governmental level there's a bunch of
books out there that I've seen that
performers have written that I I didn't
agree with is one dirt to soil by gay
but Brown this great so you know they're
others so there's if someone is out
there that does run an industrial farm
and is uh sort of tortured by it that
they're aware of the consequences of
what they're doing and they would like
to maybe and they maybe admire what
you've done and like to move in that
direction well not since you mentioned
it uh Gabe and I are both were both in
about the same age we're both industrial
Farmers that that went this
route and uh there's some great
regenerative Farmers out there but there
are a tremendous number of them that
used to be an industrial farmer just
just just not a lot of that
how many industrial Farms are there in
this country oh I have no idea a lot I
mean a lot lessen it used to be because
they've Consolidated and gotten so much
bigger but I don't know that number
that's that's well you were originally
brought uh onto that Fox News show
because they were they were trying to
figure out what a farmer thinks about
Bill Gates buying up Farmland you know
Bill G Gates who's famously said that
everyone's got to stop eating meat and
eat
these fake meat versions these
plant-based Meats so there's 25,000
factory farms factory farms continue to
take over the agricultural landscape of
the United States are currently 1.6
billion animals in our nation's 25,000
factory
farms which makes sense I mean if you
you you know go to Arby's where's that
food coming from well and you know the
an even so Jamie you should Google this
but when we talk about that um the
centralization of the meat industry is
even more star so what is it four four
um maybe four meat processors in at
least with beef occupy over
80% of the nation's beef Supply yeah CH
just gave me this before we came in here
but it's uh this is in 2023 United the
United States has
imported
956 million pounds of beef so far in
2023 wow that's imported beef wow that's
crazy Jamie will you pull up that um I
think I named it like food consolidation
or something I bet most people have no
idea I bet most people listening to this
are blown away by that number that most
people would if you asked the average
person on the street how much meat do
you think is imported from other
countries beef they would probably
say none they they wouldn't even think
of it no especially if you get to label
it a product of the USA which is so
dirty yeah you and and that's you know
consumers believe they have the
impression of choice they don't actually
have Choice the the image that Jamie's
going to show us trying to find a
cleaner one it's just a little blurry
but y here it is so look at all these
brands that are owned by this you know
10 or so parent
companies it's crazy so you know
consumers have the uh you know the
impression that there is choice but
truly there is no choice the same is
true with with meat I think on Tyson's
website it has uh and I gave it to Jamie
but one in every five pounds of meat
that's consumed in America is a Tyson
product wow whoa you so we talk about
centralized food we talk about food
security do we really want a global food
supply and the answer is yes or no but
with regards to uh fragility in food
think about coid uh and the effects of
of what it did to the grocery store
there we go one in five pounds of
chicken beef and pork in the US is
produced by Tyson
Foods wow the that's proudly registered
on their website yeah there's another
one that talks about how many animals
they slaughter in a week and that's
another just in incredible number and
the the same is the other four pound are
produced by two or three other companies
not like it was Tyson and everybody else
right right right will you pull up that
that other one Jamie because I want to
draw a correlation
between the the scale of this versus the
scale of what Farms like us
do no there's one that says like
177,000 cattle are processed
um anyways I'll tell you a little bit
about about about our model and then we
can compare it to that but so when Dad
decided to build the the uh processing
plan in 2007 he built it to process 50
head of cattle a week and we got to that
number and we were still hemorrhaging
money there was no way that was going to
work and so we made a few modifications
primarily around Refrigeration uh we
dropped the chill time this one yep
that's it so our processing plant on
Farm Processing Plant will process 25
head of cattle a day five days a week so
it's 125 head a week compared to systems
like this which is also on Tyson's
website
155,000 head of cattle are processed per
week in only 14 facilities
wow that's crazy and you know the
further to the right you go so you know
pork 471 th000 pigs are slaughtered in a
week at only seven facilities
47 million million
chicken per week and I've been in I've
been in those facilities and it's not
pretty but that that is the scale of
food hor we've uh We've shown the
footage of um someone got Drone footage
where they fly a drone over a pig farm
and industrialized pig farm and you see
these Lakes of pig waste and it's so
disgusting just just toxic waste which
is sad because that waste is what
created that top soil at White Oak
pastures it's just we took the livestock
off of the land we decoupled what had
been coupled for millions of years so
these are these Lakes now here's the
question why can't they take that waste
and redistribute it into the land and
use it for fertilizer and and there's
some of that done but it's expensive
that's the
problem that's expensive is that what
they're doing right here yeah I think so
yeah I remember them talking about the
waste was getting spread on the people's
Like
Houses cuz the it would be in the air
and then it would right of course
whatever yeah well yeah indiscriminate
because they want to do it cheaply yeah
and and there's a difference between a a
cow or pig or chicken defecating here
and there and there right and spreading
natural way you that thick across right
well and just just to sort of tie all
that together Jamie you have one more
thing and then I swear I'm going to quit
asking you to pull up but that's
what he does it's okay he likes it I
have to apologize he's probably like who
invited her no no no no but there's
there's uh one more that's like Our
Brands so one in five uh pounds of meat
we just read that was produced produced
by Tyson but consumers have no idea that
it was a Tyson product so if you look at
the amount of brands that you know these
big multinational meat corporations own
there's no no there's no uh no way for a
consumer to know that that's one of
those
products so it's just it's just a really
incredible system when you start pulling
the layers back on
it and there's a demand that's the other
problem it's like you're not going to
get them to stop doing that there's a
massive demand for all this food yeah
and most people listening to this are
part of that demand most people
listening to this have stopped at a fast
food burger place this week and and
picked up a product of this
system yeah and they want to be able to
do that if you're hungry and you're
you're on the go and you want to be able
to pull into a drive-thru get a
cheeseburger and some fries and a soda
bam takes it's kind of extraordinary the
system they've created it sucks that you
can't do it in a healthy way but it's
kind of extraordinary that you just pull
into someone and get 1,000 calories like
that so convenient cheap Che cheap
incredibly cheap yeah for the amount
amount of calories and that and that is
also reflected in the health
consequences of impoverished people if
you look at people that are poor that
rely upon this kind of food all the time
those are the people that have the worst
Health outcomes because they're eating
stuff that's doesn't have any nutrients
in it it's terrible for you it's filled
with seed oils and and
preservatives and I'm sure you've seen
those um uh they've done these uh little
tests where they've taken a McDonald's
cheeseburger and just sit it on a shelf
yeah yeah for like weeks and nothing
happens to it yeah you could probably
eat it which is so insane that's crazy I
mean you sit it for weeks but you know
these companies as bad as this is these
companies have done what the public told
them to do the public has said we want
food cheaper cheaper cheaper cheaper
cheaper cheaper quicker consist and
quicker and you know you know how you
get cheaper and quicker okay this is
exactly the same after five years oh
five years where' it go Jamie that is
wild it doesn't look that bad that is
crazy stick a fork in me I'm done wow so
Megan wants to find out whether the
cheeseburger will stay the same after
another five years so I bet it will I
mean what's going to change five years
say she's inspired to carry out the
experiment after seeing an old Burger
being showcased in her doctor's office
and so she set this burger down and just
left it out there for 5 years and that's
what it looks
like Hi
Megan kind of crazy but also disturbing
if you you eat that like what is that
doing to your gut microbiome what is
that doing to your health I mean the
preservatives have a consequence on your
health the eating stuff that you know we
were talking about dog food earlier and
um I feed my dog raw food and I just
started feeding him raw food about six
seven months ago and it kind of it's
embarrassing to me that that's the case
because I always just thought if you go
to the pet I didn't think about it you
go to the pet store you buy healthy food
uh the best food that they have
available at a you know a nice pet store
like this got to be good for the dog oh
look at all the nutrients look at all
the stuff but then I was thinking like
how is it just sitting there how can it
how how does it not go bad how does it
not there's never mold on pet food
there's the cheeseburger 20 years oh my
God a Utah man 20 well there's your
answer Megan it doesn't even look like
that one's been in the refrigerator no
just sitting there I don't think hers
was either dang this guy's just hoarding
cheeseburgers this guy's got a
14-year-old cheeseburger there's quite
quite a few of them he just breaks it
out every year for an update oh my God
that's insane that's insane the pickle
went bad yeah the pickle went bad pickle
kind of he's got it receip he's got the
receipt that's incredible how much was
it 79 cents 79 cents not much more now
which is pretty shocking yeah
but there's a
consequence